qu'avez-vous a confessé remémore un
meurtre en perd pourquoi avez-vous
commis un meurtre pour l'argent qu'ils
aient pu tuer pour de l'argent vraiment
beau mon père
après l'avoir tué tu as montré pour
attendre les instructions aller à bruges
suisse uss et ça c'est en belgique
deux semaines à bruz dans une piaule à
chier avec toi alors je me casse
monsieur blé clean oui vous savez un
message
premièrement vous voyez là demain soir
quand jean pascal coup de fil ou sa
vache vous avez ma parole ils ont qui
grossit tu trouves tu dois sortir tu
veux aller
oui je crois que j'ai une idée je
retourne à ma chambre je saute dans le
canal et j'essaie de nager pour
m'échapper en sortant tu vas jusqu'au
coin de là tu peux m'avoir si tu vis
bien on compte 1 2 3 et ses parties
ce qui compte c'est toi qui compte vous
êtes des malades à 30 ans
si j'avais compté dans une ferme mais
j'étais débile mental bruges marie
impressionné mais je suis dublin alors
certes et
c'est par la copine c'est une prostituée
savais pas qu'il y avait des prostituées
mais il faut les chercher dans le bon
sens troyes dans les bordels il y en a
un où si je fais pas partie de ces
[ __ ] de coke de los angeles je veux
une arme normal pour un homme normal
c'est peut-être ça l'enfer passer toute
l'éternité dans ce [ __ ] heureusement
ma touche pas si sceptiques au derrière